we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
we have a longtime racist caller named
troy who calls in
and he is um
parroting some of the same racist talk
about katanji brown jackson
uh including that she is not really a
judge now at the at the top of the show
we already looked
by
the standards set by the current nine
supreme court justices
um katanji brown jackson is more
qualified more qualified but troy
doesn't care nope there's something
about her she's not a real judge
there's no doubt that
the joe biden nominee for the supreme
court
canadian brown jackson is a
joke and a disgrace and of course the
constant you know mispronunciation of
her first name i think is is part of
this entire package
she's an activist
not a real judge
and i hope the republicans continue
to
bash this woman humiliating this woman
exposed this fraud
that community jackson is
and they need to do the same thing
is he saying kanina liberal democrats
these republicans need to do the same
exact thing
what they did to brett kavanaugh
and what they did back in the day the
clearance comes
to nina jackson brown or whatever the
whatever
yeah so anyway getting the name wrong
and the whatever her name is and she's
not a real judge this is a pretty common
uh racist trope and you all know that i
am very very careful
about calling things or people racist on
this show this caller troy has like a
five-year history of calling in and
making overtly racist comments and
that's an important context to
understand
this idea of being a real judge
i had an experience with this idea uh
as as applied to a uh to a black person
back when i worked at circuit city many
of you remember when i was in high
school and and at the very start of
college i worked at circuit city selling
laptops it was quite a job
and i learned a lot of things there
including how to relate to people and so
many different things but i also saw
some really ugly
racism and xenophobia firsthand we had a
manager at one point a jamaican-american
guy named lennox one of the nicest guys
and he was he was the manager he was the
manager of the store
and there was this incident where the
store would close at 9 30
and at 9 32
a customer walked in through the
employee exit so like the front doors
were already closed and this guy walks
in at 9 32 through the door that's there
for us to leave
and he grabs a dvd
and says he wants to buy it and of
course the sales systems were all shut
down it's all you know
they're they're done we're closed that
that's it and he insisted he wanted to
buy this dvd
and we explained to him you know sir
we're closed that's just it and he said
get the manager
and out comes linux and
uh lennox says
sir we're closed you know the registers
are shut off i couldn't i just can't
take your money um you're gonna have to
come back tomorrow or buy the thing
somewhere else you know i think maybe
best buys open until 10 or whatever and
the guy says
let me see the real manager there's no
way you're the manager and of course it
wasn't
definitive that what he meant is
how could this young black guy be the
manager
but we all sort of looked at each other
like it seems like this is what's going
on and then eventually you know one of
the
one of the big warehouse guys came out
and just escorted the guy out almost
like security
um and this idea of the where's the real
manager
you're not a real judge
it's a common trope and quite frankly
it's sickening on the bonus show today
we are going to talk about
the leah thomas
swimming controversy we are going to
discuss it
washington dc is suing grubhub for
allegedly using deceptive trade
practices
and mortgage rates are surging faster
than expected what will the impact be on
real estate
what will the impact be on people's rent
when people rent apartments we will talk
about all of it on today's bonus show
you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show you'll get the daily show without
commercials six hours earlier than we
make it available publicly and you'll
get priority when we do our david pakman
show viewer town halls all of those
benefits and more when you sign up at
joinpacman.com i will see you on the
bonus show